[MUSIC]
Raise your hand if you think you've
checked your phone more than a dozen times
already this morning?
>> [LAUGH].
>> How about if you think you spend too
much time checking email or
otherwise glued to a piece of technology.
I certainly do.
Too often, I find myself hunched over my
laptop in Bass Library
trying to make a dent in the day's deluge
of emails.
I'm frantically slamming away at the
keyboard,
looking up at the clock in frustration, as
my free hour of time slips away.
As soon as I think I'm making some
progress, I hit refresh.
And then.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I'm right back where I started.
Technology speeds up our lives, but it
comes at a cost.
We spend so much time reacting,
getting pulled in a million different
directions at once.
It makes it really hard to think
deliberately, to live intentionally.
Makes it hard to manage stress, foster
creativity.
But I have good news.
There's a solution.
It's the oldest trick in the book.
Step outside and get in touch with nature.
>> [LAUGH].
>> You just might like it.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
It was a brisk early winter morning in my
hometown of Boulder, Colorado.
I was just back for the Thanksgiving break
from my first eight weeks of business
school and man, was I exhausted.
I'd been sprinting non stop to keep up
with everything that this new
high speed life I'd been throwing at.
Participate in strategy class, so it looks
like I belong in this place.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Drive to a clean tech conference and
impress those potential employers.
Go out to bars, so I seem fun and make
some friends.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Squeeze every potential
ounce of value out of this opportunity,
but put on a smile.
And act like it's easy.
>> [LAUGH].
>> I was stressed out, sleep deprived.
I didn't feel like myself.
I got out of my car at Boulder Chautauqua
Park Trailhead.
Put my phone on the seat and took off
running up the mud and snow covered trail.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
I didn't know where I was going, or what I
would do when I got there.
I just knew I needed some space.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
I found that space on a rock, with a
viewpoint, overlooking the Flat Irons.
As I sat there, a nourishing silence.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Began to wash over me.
The crisp, clear mountain air filled my
lungs.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
A fresh breeze made the spruce trees sway
peacefully in the wind and
put a little extra lift under that hawk's
wing soaring overhead.
I could feel my mind slowing down.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
About an hour later,
scribbled some thoughts down in my journal
before returning to my car.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Be patient.
Be grateful.
And get outside.
I came back to Stanford that next week,
and
I could feel my feet on the ground again.
I would look my friends in the eye and be
fully present for my conversations.
I began to meditate, a practice that I
have continued to this day.
Nature can change your life.
And it is right outside your doorstep.
The benefits of interaction with nature
have
been proven to us in numerous academic
studies.
They include everything from increased
pain tolerance to better memory,
even reduced symptoms of ADHD.
Studies from top universities around the
country and the world show
that time in nature significantly reduces
stress and increases creativity.
But this wisdom's been around for long
before the academic studies.
Many world languages have words
specifically for
the concept that getting outside is good
for the mind, body, and spirit.
In Norwegian, that word is [FOREIGN].
>> [LAUGH].
>> The Japanese word [FOREIGN] translates
directly into English as forest bathing.
>> [LAUGH].
>> Many of our world's most creative and
brilliant people seem to share the same
wisdom.
Albert Einstein once told us, look deep
into nature and
then you'll understand everything better.
Perhaps, it's no coincidence that both the
Buddha and
Isaac Newton came to their world-altering
realizations while sitting beneath a tree.
>> [LAUGH].
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> I wonder what our world might look like
if we all looked deep into nature
more often.
It shouldn't be that hard, right?
Can find nature basically everywhere.
Well, the sad part is, based on the latest
statistics, you probably won't.
As our culture spends more and more time
interacting with technology,
we're spending less and less time
interacting with nature.
Since the mid-1980s,
the average time spent outside by the
American child has dropped in half.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
25% fewer American adults participate in
outdoor recreation.
Meanwhile, the time we spend in front of
screens has skyrocketed.
In the US, we're now up to an average of
seven and a half hours a day.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
New York Times bestselling author, Richard
Louv, has a name for this crisis.
He calls it Nature Deficit Disorder.
And I think it's pretty serious.
But the good news is the antidote is
abundant.
In fact, you can find it anywhere on this
campus.
You just have to go looking for it.
Louv calls it vitamin N for nature.
Take it regularly.
Turn your phone on silent and go lay out
on the grass for a while.
Take a walk around and really observe the
intricacies of the bushes and the trees.
Open yourself up.
Let nature come pouring in.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
When I finished my hike above Boulder last
Thanksgiving,
my vitamin N levels were at a pretty good
high.
But they slowly started coming back down
again over time.
By the time last summer rolled around, I
was feeling pretty down.
This time it was a deeper more existential
kind of low.
You see my dream job, a summer internship,
turned out to not have this elusive get me
out of bed in the morning quality I had
been searching for.
I felt lost, confused, alone.
In my search for a happy and meaningful
life.
So at the end of my summer, I decided to
embark on a vision quest.
A two-week introspective journey in
nature,
culminating with a four-day wilderness
solo in the desert of Southern Utah.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
That journey.
The mornings I was woken up with the
desert sunlight on my face.
The towering sandstone monoliths that
stood above me and seemed to wait for
me to ask just the right question.
The deafening violence of the
thunderstorm.
The deafening silence of the watercolor
sunset.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
That journey may not fit fully into words,
but
what I can put into words is the impact
that it's had on me.
I now know what it feels like to listen
fully to my own inner compass.
I've overcome numerous mental and
emotional barriers that have stifled me my
entire life.
I found a deeper vision for my future for
how I hope to give my life to this world.
That journey in the desert is the reason
that I'm standing here giving this
talk today.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So, what's your next step in your own
personal journey in nature?
Doesn't have to be a four-day wilderness
solo,
but I do hope that it pushes you just a
little bit beyond what you're used to.
You might have to invest a little extra
time and effort up front to get out there.
Well, I assure you, the return on your
investment will be worth it.
>> [LAUGH].
>> You will come back clear headed, more
productive, and less stressed.
And what's more, you will fuel your soul.
For me, nature is the ultimate freedom.
The natural world doesn't judge me.
It welcomes me for exactly who I am.
Nature brings me clarity, humility, and
infinite possibility.
A starlit sky reminds me that I am so
small, but
that I'm a part of something so big and
incredible.
Nature makes me fully alive and present in
every moment.
A mountaintop view brings me out of my
thoughts and
envelops me in the wonder of the miracle
of life.
Thoreau once said, I took a walk in the
woods.
And I came out taller than the trees.
I wonder what some time in nature might
mean for you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]